there is some good news this morning
it's in the fight against the
coronavirus the numbers are still
unfortunately very high but nationwide
daily covet cases are in steep decline
they're down by more than half from the
peak of this omicron surge we're also
getting new guidance from the cdc on
quarantining your kids that are younger
than five after being exposed to the
virus as meg oliver shows us it can be a
very tricky situation for parents
it's a busy morning at the lag negro
house as their four girls get ready for
school
after breakfast mom taryn takes
four-year-old genevieve and 22 month old
ria to daycare my youngest was actually
born like two weeks after the pandemic
started so
it's been pretty much non-stop since
then and the unpredictability is crazy
with her youngest kids ineligible for
coveted vaccines that unpredictability
finally led lag negro to leave her
corporate job in september whenever
there was an exposure
everything shut down the little ones
would have to just stay home and it was
impossible to really work when that was
going on how many times were your
youngest sent home
i think they each had two times that
they had to quarantine throughout the
fall
for how long 10 days for each of them
new guidance from the cdc now says
children under five who are exposed to
covet 19 only need to quarantine for
five days if asymptomatic
but any quarantine at all is still
disruptive to day care centers
says the pleasant day owner sandy
valcone the hardest part for us is the
constant
fear of closing down classrooms
with somebody getting it how much of a
financial burden is that on you well our
teachers still get paid our parents have
been wonderful and they have been paying
the tuition if it is twice in a month we
do give them the credit back can you
sustain that well we budgeted for it i
don't know that
for how long data from the bureau of
labor statistics shows the collapse of
the number of child care jobs at the
start of the pandemic and while roughly
90 percent of all jobs lost since
february 2020 have been recovered
employment numbers fell again from
september to december as the omicron
variant surged parents
are totally at their breaking point and
a lot of there's a lot of
careers that are at their breaking point
between healthcare workers and teachers
but parents you know parenthood is a
career too
now since the cdc just updated their
guideline guidelines last friday falcone
told us they must wait for the new
jersey department of health to adopt
them once that happens kids in daycare
will only have to quarantine for five
days instead of eight nate
meg thank you